la proposition de loi est adopté à
l'unanimité pendant que les négociations
se poursuivent au bourget vers un accord
sur le climat à l'assemblée nationale
française a voté hier à l'unanimité une
série de mesures pour lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire
c'est un véritable fléau qui vous allez
voir coûte cher à travers le monde
frédéric la france a donc pris les
grands moyens oui parce qu'en fait
chaque année chaque français en france
va gaspiller 20 kg de nourriture donc il
prend directement le chemin de la
poubelle alors on va essayer de réduire
de 50% le gaspillage d'ici 2025
comment y arriver on va notamment forcé
les grandes surfaces donc laisser les
épiceries les supermarchés de plus de
400 mètres carrés a donné
obligatoirement tous les a vendues à des
organismes de bienfaisance et s'ils ne
le font pas il y aura des sanctions
c'est genre de mesures qui existent déjà
depuis deux ans maintenant en belgique
où là en fait tout les commerces qui ne
respectent pas ce genre de lois doivent
débourser une amende de 7500 $
il peut être même aura peut-être retrait
de son permis d'exploitation va pas
aussi loin chez nous mais il ya quand
même des ententes je crois avec des
supermarché de leur marché entre autres
le parlant du film de ce phénomène parce
que c'est mondiale en fait ça existe un
peu partout ce gaspillage alimentaire
oui en fait vraiment les chiffres sont
un écran il regarde j'ai mis tous les
héros pour vous montrer un petit peu à
quel point c'est désastreux c'est 1300
milliards de kilos qui prennent le
chemin de la poubelle chaque année à
travers le monde
ça en fait c'est un tiers de la
production alimentaire mondiale qui s'en
va dans la poubelle ça représente 1100
17 milliards de gaspillage c'est
hallucinant et en plus sacrés de la
pollution figurez vous parce que ça crée
7 % des gaz à effet de serre à travers
le monde
et si le gaspillage alimentaire était en
fait un pays ce serait le troisième pays
émetteur après la chine et les états
unis
alors il le canada dans tout ça alors le
canada il n'ya pas de quoi pavoiser en
fait quand on regarde les chiffres 31
milliards d'argent perdues à cause du
gaspillage c'est 2% du pib quand même
ces normes plus de la presque la moitié
s'en va dans les poubelles des maisons
alors qu'il ya 900 mille canadiens qui
peut ont recours aux banques
alimentaires derniers chiffres avant la
digestion belgique donc on jette chaque
année pour 260 dollars de nourriture
états unis 462 ou et le québec
malheureusement c'est le champion 771
dollars gaspillage alimentaire acheter
moins consommer mieux merci frédéric
qu'ils ont pris